jetliners are basically flying homes
it's a sealed pressure canister it's
incredibly strong it will last
practically forever
[Music]
I'm Bruce Campbell and you're inside the
cockpit area of my 727 home I can
appreciate that some folks might feel a
bit isolated or that it might simply
strike them as an unusual living
environment but for me it's always felt
completely natural my entry is via the
after stairs which are retractable and
are retracted whenever I leave for an
extended time the after II of the
aircraft now is my living space my very
primitive shower is located there the
two natural after laboratories are both
functional sleeping quarters are there
in the form of a simple futon sofa and
bench where I spend lots of time
embellishing elements of the aircraft
jetliners retire at the rate of about
three per day for the most part I think
we shred them and then we spin around
180 degrees and make a home after having
just shredded an aerospace class home
sized structure if you are an
extraterrestrial looking down on this
behavior you'd wonder whether this
species has all his marbles in place or
not
[Music]
people have asked me whether it crashed
here and I simply restored the wreck
that's an odd thing to hear it's it's
completely impractical next time you're
in the jetliner close your eyes for a
moment in your mind remove all the seats
and all the other people and then open
your eyes with that vision and consider
the expanse of the living room it's a
good environment it really is
[Music]